To his friends, he was the Blond Beast.
To his enemies, he was the Hangman, or the
Butcher of Prague.
To the man he devoted his life to, he was
the Man with the Iron Heart.
During his life, Reinhard Heydrich was known
by many names, too numerous to list here.
But you probably associate him with one name
in particular: Heydrich was the Nazi target
of Operation Anthropoid.
A talented classical musician who threw it
all away to become a military man, Heydrich
was the Nazi ideal made flesh.
He was tall.
Blond.
Cultured.
A lover of Wagner.
He was also brutal.
It was under Heydrich’s watch that the infamous
Einsatzgruppen were formed, under his direction
that Nazi enemies were killed, and to his
designs that the Holocaust was perpetrated.
Assassinated by the Czechoslovak resistance
in Prague in 1942, Heydrich is a mystery:
a sensitive, cultured boy who somehow grew
up to be one of history’s worst monsters.
Join us today as we journey into Prague’s
heart of darkness.
A Young Lad of Promise
If you were shown the conditions Heydrich
was born into and asked to guess what you
thought he’d grow up to be, “genocidal
maniac” would probably be far down your
list.
Born Reinhard Eugen Tristan Heydrich on March
7, 1904, the world baby Reinhard came into
was one of middle class luxury.
His father Bruno was an opera aficionado who
ran a music conservatory in the German town
of Halle, near Leipzig, while his mother,
Elisabeth, was a pianist from a wealthy family.
For young Heydrich, that meant a life of culture,
money, and – most importantly – music.
Music was the air the family breathed.
Bruno wrote his own operas and sang on stage,
while Elisabeth had little Heydrich trained
to exacting classical standards on the violin
and cello.
But there was a cloud hovering over the family’s
charmed life, a cloud that only really counts
as a cloud if you live surrounded by German
nationalists.
Everyone in Halle thought Bruno was Jewish.
You may be thinking “um, so what?”
But Bruno didn’t feel that way.
He was certain his supposed Jewish background
was why his opera career never really took
off.
As time went on, he began to loathe the religion
he blamed for his own failings.
And he made sure young Heydrich loathed it
too.
Still, this unpleasantness aside, their family
life was relatively normal.
Elisabeth was a strict mother, determined
her son should succeed, and soon Heydrich
was not just an accomplished musician, but
a powerful sportsman too.
This normal family appearance only began to
crack in 1914.
Like many Germans, the Heydrichs were at first
excited by WWI’s outbreak, thinking it’d
be an easy win for their country.
But, as first the weeks dragged on, then the
months, and finally the years, that optimism
began to fade.
In the winter of 1916-17, fuel and food shortages
brought on by the war led to starvation and
misery across the nation.
In Halle, work at Bruno’s conservatory dried
up as the economy faltered.
As 1917 rolled on, the German population grew
angry at the war’s management.
They began striking, protesting.
Before long, the cities were in turmoil, as
running street battles erupted between far
right nationalists and Communists.
Halle wasn’t spared.
As a teen, Heydrich watched left and right
extremists battle for control of his city’s
streets.
Unlike his terrified parents, Heydrich found
the clashes intoxicating.
In October, 1918, German dreams of winning
the war finally collapsed with a resounding
crash.
Germany removed the Kaiser from power and
brought in a civilian government tasked with
negotiating peace.
In the aftermath, whole segments of the military
went into rebellion.
Before the war had even ended on November
11, the country was in revolution.
As a Communist uprising seized control of
Berlin, Heydrich decided he had to make a
stand.
In Halle, the now nearly 16 year old boy joined
a local Freikorps unit.
Intended as an anti-Communist militia, the
Freikorps soon bloomed into a far right paramilitary
force that targeted Jews and revolutionaries
alike.
For the teenage Heydrich, the experience was
an eye-opener.
For the first time in his life, he was surrounded
by people who felt like he did.
People who shared his anti-Semitic beliefs,
his dislike of Communists.
His desire to use violence.
By 11 August, the country was back under control.
The Weimar Republic was founded, and Germany
began to adjust to its new life as a democratic
nation.
But the revolution of 1919 had unleashed the
forces of far right nationalism.
And Heydrich wasn’t the only one to heed
their siren call.
A Sick Republic
The early days of the Weimar Republic were
marked by a never-ending series of political
wildfires.
On March 13, 1920, an ultranationalist putsch
captured Berlin and held the city for a few
days before the government regained control.
Three years later, another rightwing putsch,
this time in Munich, killed 20 people.
It’s leader?
One Adolf Hitler.
You might be expecting to hear that Heydrich
was in the thick of all this, cheering on
the Nazis.
Well, you’d be wrong.
After the Freikorps disbanded, Heydrich had
hung around in Halle just long enough to get
his high school diploma, in 1922.
He’d then high-tailed it out of his hometown
as fast as he could.
But he hadn’t gone running to the Nazi party.
Heydrich had joined the German Navy.
By 1922, Weimar Germany was in the grip of
hyperinflation.
The economy was in ruins.
Anyone who wanted a roof over their head and
three square meals a day joined the military.
And Heydrich wanted more than that.
Now a lad of 18, he was ambitious.
He wanted to become an admiral.
He still flirted with the far right, maintaining
membership of the anti-Semitic Deutscher Schutz
und Truzbund.
But while most future high-ranking Nazis were
passionate true believers who were willing
to forego a normal life for their cause, Heydrich
wasn’t like that.
He wanted a respectable career with responsibility.
When Hitler published Mein Kampf from his
jail cell in 1925, Heydrich didn’t even
bother to read it.
By 1928, Heydrich’s diligent good work had
paid off enough for him to be promoted to
first lieutenant and assigned to Navy Intelligence.
While he was still taunted for his supposed
Jewish roots, the bullying he used to receive
for his cultured side was long gone.
Now a grown man, Heydrich’s sensitive qualities
were no longer a burden.
In fact, they made him something of a catch.
Throughout the late 1920s and early 1930s,
Heydrich sowed his wild oats like a man hoping
to rival the Quakers in breakfast production.
It was during this seductive phase that Heydrich
met Lina von Osten.
Aged just 19, Lina was everything Heydrich
wanted in a woman.
She was charming, intelligent, in awe of him.
And she was a fervent National Socialist.
By 1930, the Nazis were well known in Germany.
But they weren’t yet in charge.
When Heydrich first met Lina, he actually
made fun of her for being a Nazi, calling
the leadership clowns and deriding Goebbels
as a “cripple”.
Little did the ambitious sailor know he was
only a few short months away from joining
those clowns.
In early 1931, Heydrich proposed to Lina.
He then forwarded a copy of the engagement
announcement to another girl he was seeing,
as a way of breaking up with her.
But Heydrich’s classy methods soon returned
to bite his Germanic arsch when the girl’s
father found the announcement and hit the
roof.
He actually complained to the Navy!
And the Navy responded by actually firing
Heydrich!
On April 30, 1931, Heydrich was discharged.
When he got the news, the future Butcher of
Prague locked himself in his room and cried
like a baby for days on end.
When Heydrich finally emerged from his epic
cry-a-thon, Lina was all like “dude, this
is perfect.
You can get a job with the Nazis!”
At first, Heydrich wasn’t enthusiastic.
His main sticking point was that he didn’t
think there were good enough career prospects.
But Lina kept pushing him and, eventually,
he joined up, becoming member 544,916.
It was the beginning of a rise toward infamy.
Making a Monster
At this point, you might be wondering how
Heydrich the lothario sailor became Heydrich
the Nazi.
The answer is, surprisingly: his grandmother.
By the time Heydrich joined the Nazis, his
mother and grandmother were already enthusiastic
members.
And they’d carried their wealth and connections
into their new lives.
Within a month of Heydrich joining, his grandmother
had arranged a private meeting between Heydrich
and SS leader Heinrich Himmler.
It’s gotta be said, Himmler wasn’t all
that happy.
The only thing that convinced him to go was
that Heydrich’s grandmother had inflated
her grandkid’s connections to Naval intelligence,
which might be useful to the Nazis.
When the two met in Munich, Himmler curtly
gave Heydrich twenty minutes to outline a
counterintelligence operation for the Nazi
Party.
Twenty minutes later, the Blackshirts’ leader
collected his jaw off the floor and offered
Heydrich a job.
Heydrich had aced the interview.
Despite only ever holding a low position in
Naval Intelligence, he managed to use all
his knowledge to outline an effective strategy.
When he hit a blank spot in his knowledge,
he improvised, using the plots of half-remembered
spy novels.
And it worked.
Himmler recruited Heydrich into the SD – the
SS intelligence branch – then and there.
It was the beginning of a partnership that
would eventually leave Europe in ruins.
Although Himmler is infamous in his own right,
he and Heydrich could be seen as a double
act: the Laurel and Hardy of mass murder.
During the Night of the Long Knives, in 1934,
Himmler and Heydrich worked together to exterminate
the powerholders in the SA – the Nazi Brownshirts.
One of those killed was SA leader Ernst Rohm,
godfather to Heydrich’s own child.
In the aftermath, Himmler awarded Heydrich
by promoting him to Chief of the Gestapo.
It was just the first in a sequence of events
we’re gonna call “Himmler promoting Heydrich
like crazy”.
In June, 1936, for example, Himmler merged
the SD, the German criminal police, and the
Gestapo into a single unit and gave it to
Heydrich.
Three years later, in September, 1939, Himmler
consolidated every single intelligence operation
across the entire Third Reich under Heydrich.
The new Reich Security Main Office (RSHA)
was so powerful even other Nazis were kept
in the dark about its existence.
Not that Heydrich didn’t earn his new position.
For a guy who once called the Nazis clowns,
Heydrich had taken to his new job like a fascist
duck to water.
In November, 1938, he’d directly organized
the looting and burning of Jewish property
known as Kristallnacht.
A year later, in August, 1939, Heydrich had
also masterminded the false flag attack on
Geliwitz that gave the Nazis a pretext for
invading Poland.
In fact, many of the most infamous Nazi actions
can be traced back to this one opera lover
from Halle.
After the invasion of Poland in September
1939, for example, Heydrich was put in charge
of the Einsatzgruppen.
The Einsatzgruppen were death squads that
followed in the wake of invading German armies,
mopping up enemies of the Reich.
Their brutality was legendary.
In the first three months after the occupation
of Poland, they murdered 50,000.
When the Nazis pushed east, in 1941, it was
even worse.
Over 33,000 Jews were killed in just two days
in Kiev by Einsatzgruppen.
Not that Heydrich’s crimes only happened
abroad.
In 1939, as Germany went to war, Heydrich
had instructed his security service to focus
on the Reich’s internal enemies.
In the dying days of that year, officers fanned
out across German territory, liquidating gypsies,
Freemasons, homosexuals, Jehovah’s Witnesses,
intellectuals.
Taken together, it was a tsunami of bloodshed.
A wave of annihilation unlike anything Europe
had seen in generations.
And the worst was yet to come.
“The Eternal Subhuman”
On November 12, 1938, Reinhard Heydrich reported
on the Jewish question to a gathering of Nazis.
Referring to Europe’s Jews as “the eternal
subhuman”, he declared that imprisoning
them wouldn’t be enough, and that the Reich
would have to get rid of them.
Not three months later, Hermann Goering took
Heydrich to one side, and told him to “solve
the Jewish problem”.
At this stage, what Goering meant was a policy
of forced emigration and brutal tactics that
would chase the Jews out of Germany.
But, even in early 1939, it was clear the
Blond Beast wouldn’t stop at emigration.
It started after the invasion of Poland.
As the Einsatzgruppen were unleashing Hell,
Heydrich and Adolf Eichmann quietly worked
together to have all of Austria’s Jews rounded
up and deported.
Later that year, Heydrich directed the opening
of ghettoes in Lodz, Krakow, and Warsaw.
He ensured conditions within them were so
bad that hundreds of thousands would die of
disease.
Although extermination was not yet official
Reich policy, Heydrich knew what his superiors
really wanted to do.
And, alongside his old buddy Himmler, he set
out to ensure it would happen.
In May, 1941, Heydrich issued an order forbidding
Jews to leave the Reich, claiming a “final
solution” was being prepared.
On July 31 that year, Nazi high command gave
Heydrich its blessing to devise a workable
plan for this “final solution.”
It was from these black and twisted roots
that the poison fruit of the Holocaust was
born.
Now, many people were implicit in the Holocaust
– not least Heydrich’s BFF Himmler – and
we wouldn’t want to let them off the hook
by making it appear like it was Heydrich’s
work alone.
That being said, the Blond Beast was intimately
involved in planning the 20th Century’s
worst genocide.
On January 20, 1942, Heydrich summoned leading
Nazis to the Berlin suburb of Wannsee for
a conference.
Over a three course lunch, Heydrich led a
genial discussion on his plans to rid Europe
of its Jews.
His idea was to march all 11 million east,
letting them die through starvation and exposure
along the way.
The survivors would then be interred in labor
camps and worked to death, with any that persistently
survived finally exterminated by hand.
When the Wannsee Conference disbanded, the
fate of the Reich’s Jews had been sealed.
The Holocaust was now official Nazi policy,
and it’s chief architect was determined
to get started as soon as possible.
But Heydrich wasn’t going to live to see
his murderous idea made flesh.
Vengeance was about to come from a very unlikely
source.
The “Vermin”
Reinhard Heydrich wasn’t aware of it as
he stepped out into the cold Berlin air after
the Wannsee Conference, but, far away, two
men were already plotting his murder.
Their names were Jan Kubiš, and Jozef Gabčík.
They were former Czechoslovak citizens who’d
escaped abroad and been trained by British
Intelligence.
And they were going to kill the Blond Beast.
The wheels of fate that would set Heydrich,
Kubiš, and Gabčík on a collision course
had first begun turning nearly three and a
half years earlier.
In early October, 1938, the governments of
France and Britain had agreed to the German
annexation of Czechoslovakia’s Sudetenland
region.
Of course, this soon turned out to be a case
of “give a Nazi an inch, and they’ll take
your entire country,” and five months later,
German troops invaded Czechoslovakia.
In Slovakia, a Nazi puppet regime was installed,
while the area of modern-day Czech Republic
became the Protectorate of Bohemia and Moravia,
under direct German rule.
The German invasion of Czechoslovakia wasn’t
as brutal as later invasions, like those of
Poland and the USSR.
Czech industry was considered too vital to
the German war effort to risk disrupting,
so the Nazi mass executions of the period
usually involved dozens, rather than hundreds
or thousands of victims.
In fact, the Nazis were so comparatively soft
touch in the Protectorate that a healthy resistance
movement sprang up, engaging in frequent acts
of sabotage.
It was this sabotage that brought Heydrich
onto the scene.
On September 24, 1941, Hitler sacked the former
Protector of Bohemia and Moravia in a fit
of pique at all these insolent Czechs playing
Švejk to his glorious Reich.
In place of the old guy, Heydrich was called
in to whip Prague into shape.
Heydrich was not a fan of Czechs.
Prior to his posting, he’d referred to his
new subjects as “the Czech vermin”.
On arriving in Prague, he arranged to have
142 people hanged in just five days.
It was a mission statement.
A promise of the blood that would flow through
the cobbled streets of Prague if the Czechs
didn’t start playing nice.
It was also Heydrich’s own death warrant.
In London, the Czechoslovak government in
exile watched Heydrich take his new posting
with a feeling of impotence.
Already, the exiled Czechs and Slovaks were
unpopular among their British hosts for their
apparent unwillingness to take hard action.
While Polish pilots were shooting down German
bombers and the French Resistance was engaging
in life or death escapades, the Czechs were
seemingly content to just sabotage a few factories.
The exiled government needed a piece of concrete
heroism they could show the world, to prove
they weren’t the weak partners in the fight
against Nazi rule.
In Heydrich, they found the perfect cause.
On October 3, 1941, the exiled Czechoslovak
government informed Britain’s Special Operations
Executive that they were going to assassinate
Heydrich.
The Brits were all like “you guys are actually
gonna do something?
Great, let’s kill a Nazi!”
Less than a month later, Slovak warrant officer
Jozef Gabčík was chosen for the special
mission.
He was initially joined by Czech soldier Karel
Svoboda, but Svoboda injured himself and was
replaced by Czech Staff Sargant Jan Kubiš.
Two months later, just after Christmas, Kubiš
and Gabčík parachuted alongside several
Czechoslovak commandos into the wintery landscape
outside Prague under the cover of night.
As the men moved silently through the snow
towards the distant glow of the ancient city,
the citizens of Bohemia slept soundly in their
beds.
No-one could have known what a firestorm was
about to be unleashed.
“Resembling a human”
The name chosen for the plan to assassinate
Heydrich was Operation Anthropoid, a word
which means “resembling a human.”
It was the perfect name for a plan to assassinate
the most inhuman human of all.
Back in Prague, Heydrich had spent his few
short months as Protector pacifying first
the city, then the country.
The capital had seen the promised bloodshed,
with some 400 civilians sent to the gallows.
In the wider Protectorate, around 5,000 had
been imprisoned and tortured.
But Heydrich hadn’t just gone in guns blazing
and noose swinging.
It was widely accepted that treating the Czechs
like the Poles would hamper the German war
effort.
So he’d deployed kindness, too.
Under Heydrich, rations had been increased.
Wages raised.
Pensions subsidized.
It was a cynical move straight out the far
right playbook: stuff gold down the population’s
throats to distract them from your crimes.
It had also worked.
As spring, 1942 rolled into view, Heydrich
was able to report the Czechs were pacified.
His carrot and machinegun tactics had seen
sabotage rates plummet.
Factory productivity was booming.
Nazi occupation seemed so accepted that Heydrich
even felt comfortable motoring around Prague
in an open topped car, with only a handgun
and his armed driver for protection.
But Prague wasn’t quite as pacified as Heydrich
thought.
Somewhere in the old alleyways of the city,
Kubiš and Gabčík laid low in the house
of an unsuspecting family, plotting their
next move.
They’d made contact with the Czech Resistance
months ago, and were now feeling deeply frustrated.
A plan to assassinate Heydrich on a road near
his house had been called off at the last
minute.
Another plan to kill him on a train had been
aborted.
They’d now been in Prague nearly five months,
and Heydrich was still alive.
It was at this point that someone suggested
killing Heydrich on his morning drive to work.
On Heydrich’s regular route, there was a
hairpin corner.
Anyone driving around it would have to slow
to a near-crawl.
In other words, it was the perfect place to
kill someone in an open top car.
On the morning of May 27, 1942, Gabčík and
Kubiš waited in a tram stop by the corner.
They were dressed in civilian clothes, but
there was nothing innocent about them.
Under his coat, Gabčík had a Sten gun, while
Kubiš had an anti-tank grenade hidden in
a briefcase.
As the city came to life around them, the
two men waited for their date with destiny.
Shortly after they arrived, Heydrich’s car
came into view.
As predicted, the driver slowed for the corner.
Gabčík casually stepped into the street,
turned, and opened fire with his submachinegun.
At least, that was the plan.
What really happened was Gabčík’s gun
jammed.
As he frantically tried to fire the fatal
shot, Heydrich’s expression turned from
one of surprise to white hot anger.
Ordering his driver to stop, Heydrich grabbed
his own gun, and raised it at Gabčík.
The Slovak just had time to see the barrel
train on him when the explosion hit.
The second Heydrich’s car had stopped, Kubiš
had hurled his briefcase bomb.
He was actually off target.
The grenade exploded behind the car, knocking
all three men down, but killing no-one.
Heydrich staggered to his feet and opened
fire on Kubiš, but blast had stunned him
and the bullets went wild.
Kubiš grabbed a bicycle and escaped, certain
the assassination had failed.
Screaming at his driver to get that bastard!,
Heydrich ran after Gabčík, firing at the
Slovak’s sprinting form.
They ran one street, two… when something
odd happened.
Heydrich, the consummate sportsman, found
he couldn’t run.
He was out of breath.
After a couple of hundred meters, he collapsed
on the ground, raised a hand to his side.
It came away sticky with blood.
The briefcase bomb had missed its target,
but the shrapnel hadn’t.
As the rear of the car was torn to bits, a
lump of jagged metal had been propelled deep
inside Heydrich’s body.
The Blond Beast didn’t know it, but he was
already dead.
Massacre
In the end, it took Reinhard Heydrich eight
whole days to die.
For a while, it actually looked as if he might
recover.
But then septicemia set in and the cultured
young man from Halle passed away on June 4.
The response was immediate.
In Berlin, Hitler demanded the heads of 10,000
Czechs.
On June 10, SS units walked into the Czech
village of Lidice and fulfilled the Fuhrer’s
demand.
All the men and boys of Lidice were shot dead,
all the women and girls loaded into trucks
and sent to concentration camps.
When it was discovered 11 men were outside
the village on business, Nazi agents were
sent to track them down and murder them too.
All the pets and animals in the village were
rounded up and shot.
Finally the buildings were set on fire.
The Nazis filmed the whole thing, intending
Lidice to be a warning to the world.
In Prague, revenge mass killings were carried
out, resulting in 1,300 dead.
Another Czech village – Ležáky – was
targeted and also destroyed.
It was like the Angel of Death had swept across
the land, like Heydrich’s poisonous soul
was carrying out one last killing spree before
returning to Hell.
Three weeks after the assassination, a Czech
collaborator, Karel Čurda, passed on the
hiding place of Gabčík and Kubiš to the
Gestapo.
The two assassins were in the basement of
Prague’s Cathedral Church of Sts Cyril and
Methodius.
On June 18, 1942, 700 soldiers converged on
the church.
Gabčík and Kubiš held them off for some
hours before committing suicide in the Cathedral
crypt.
The bullet holes from the firefight can still
be seen today.
In the West, the reaction to Heydrich’s
assassination was equally swift and decisive.
The image of Lidice in flames spurred the
Allies to tear up the Munich Agreement.
Until this moment in 1942, it was still possible
that a postwar settlement might allow the
Germans to keep the Sudetenland.
With images of Lidice fresh in everyone’s
minds, that was no longer an option.
It was thanks to this one assassination that
Czechoslovakia was able to remain a nation
after WWII.
But what about Heydrich?
Heydrich was the only high ranking Nazi to
be assassinated in the whole of WWII, a fact
that explains our continued fascination with
him.
But beyond Operation Anthropoid, Heydrich
deserves to be remembered.
He was the man who outlined the blueprint
for the Holocaust.
The man who controlled the infamous Einsatzgruppen.
It was under his watch that the notorious
Polish ghettoes were created.
Had he lived longer, it’s undoubtable that
he would have committed more atrocities.
Unlike nearly every other leading Nazi, there’s
no indication Heydrich was a true believer
in the early days.
More an opportunist who took a job to please
his fiancée and then did that job with bloodthirsty
relish.
In many ways, that makes him even scarier
than someone like his old buddy Himmler.
We like to think of people as either inherently
good or inherently evil, but Heydrich wasn’t
inherently anything.
He was just a blank, a hollow man.
In another life he probably would have made
a boringly average Naval commander.
But Heydrich didn’t live another life.
He lived this one, with all its bloodshed.
In the end, perhaps all we can say is that
the shy, sensitive boy from Halle was simply
the perfect anthropoid.
A creature that looked human without ever
feeling even the faintest flicker of humanity.